oui
[Musique]
bienvenue dans la grande interview
consacrée aujourd'hui à isabelle coûtant
peyre un avocat elle tient à ce qu'on le
formule comme ça un avocat à part
anticonformiste ancien associé de
jacques vergès depuis les années 80 elle
a défendu notamment de nombreuses
affaires de terrorisme à la sueur et la
défense ainsi du terroriste carlos plus
récemment du principal accusé dans la
sphère de la tuerie de charlie hebdo et
d'un grand nombre de d'ennemi public
numéro 1 et 2 figure controversée
bonjour m coûtant peyre merci d'avoir
accepté cet entretien d'abord je
voudrais saluer la grande russie et puis
également sa maison-mère girerd la
grande union soviétique qui a donné tant
des sports monde entier alors parlons du
procès de charlie hebdo parce que
c'était un procès dans lequel vous avez
plaidé
donc votre client dit qu'il est innocent
il a été condamné à 30 ans de prison et
donc vous avait interjeté appel comment
vous avez vécu ce procès c'était
extrêmement pénible parce que c'était un
procès qui était partial alors on a
renversé les choses un procès c'est
quand même pour juger des gens donc sur
sa durée à peu près trois mois
finalement il ya eu quasiment un mois où
c'était la parole des victimes
alors les victimes j'ai tout les
compassions pour eux simplement il faut
désigner les vrais les vrais
responsables et non pas prendre trouver
des gars qu'on va prendre comme alibi
d'une soi disant bonne justice pour
vengeance venger ce qui s'est passé donc
c'est surtout ça que j'ai reprochait
c'était assez pénible
c'était un spectacle était organisé au
millimètre près c'est à dire ou un
tournage de film c'est réellement un
tournage d'un film scénarisé à l'avancé
ça marche comme ça pour les tournages de
films et il fallait pas que ça dérape
alors ça a dérapé en raison du de la
grave maladie qui a atteint mon client à
lire les accolades c'est à dire ils ont
caché qu'il était il avait attrapé le
le pot vide et puis eux
il a salement attrapé parce qu'il était
très malade pendant longtemps c'était
l'affolement général parce que ça
déglingue est le programme et puis pour
vous dire que c'était tellement politisé
au plus haut niveau de l'état que quand
même monsieur macron sur les bons
conseils de son cher ministre de la
justice ancien avocat donc eric dupond
moretti a pondu a décrit décidant que
finalement on peut se passer d'un accusé
il fallait que le programme continue
c'est quand même incroyable ça n'était
jamais arrivé
c'est à dire espèce de coup d'état
contre la justice et contre les droits
des accusés
au-delà de ça vous contestez
l'instruction il ya une instruction
évident à dire que le vendeur d'armes
n'a pas être inculpé hier les donneurs
d'ordre dont les a pas retrouvées mais
mais c'est honteux
et tout ça c'est honteux c'est à dire
que dès le départ ils savaient très bien
qu'ils étaient les vrais responsables
il aurait pu éviter de tuer les auteurs
au moins on aurait su un peu plus et ça
aurait été un vrai procès parce que
quand vous avez des forces spéciales
vous avez des gars soient actives tout
seul soit deux types qui sont épuisés
c'est pas tellement dur de les attraper
vivant mais ça l'état voulait pas et
ensuite on fait un habillage alors que
1,7 tout de suite d'où viennent les
armes
et puis on va inventer d'aller trouver
des gars qui sont plus ou moins les
potes on va dire de de coulibaly il n'y
avait pas un seul type qui connaissait
les kwasi danse princesse quand même
extraordinaire
bon donc les vendeurs d'armes comme par
hasard c'est des gens de droite des bons
chrétiens survivalistes marchand d'armes
fous de la gâchette on va dire et on
sait que maintenant il ya quand même pas
mal de violences en france avec ses
mouvements politiques survivalistes et
bien selon le juge d'instruction mais
enfin ça veut dire c'est au plus haut
niveau de l'état le juge d'instruction
n'a fait qu'exécuter les ordres
on a tous plantés et c'est des gens qui
ont été libérés assez vite ils ont été
un peu poursuivi pour trafic d'armes
il devait c'est le seul qui devait être
dans le box et personne d'autre vous
avez assuré la défense pas seulement d'
ali riza paul atteint mais de nombreux
accusés dans des affaires de terrorisme
qu'est ce que vous retenez de
qu'ils sont semblables à la perception
qu'on en a la perception des médias
vous savez les terminologies que soit le
mot terroriste que ce soit le mot
islamiste que ce soit intégristes je
sais pas ils inventent toutes sortes de
formules
c'est en réalité ces deux là c'est de la
communication
bon alors je sais que ça tout le monde
le sait les grands terroristes
c'est à dire ceux qui ont le droit de la
violence légale soit disant c'est les
états mais quand vous voyez les
équipements armés de toutes les sortes
de police rien qu'en france s'effrayant
effroyable et eux ils ont vraiment un
droit à la violence soit disant légal
donc ces affaires-là vous savez il ya à
la fois de la discrimination dans les
prisons en france il ya peu près je
pense entre 70% et 80% de musulmans et
pas de chiffres officiels sur les
statistiques ans en prison donc un jeu
juste alors c'est d'une part ça concerne
des populations qu'ils sont c'est pas
des gens qui travaillent avec bernard
arnault ça c'est clair
et deuxièmement c'est aussi parce qu'ils
sont musulmans vous vous souvenez de
cette histoire aussi qui est arrivé
pendant ce procès où monsieur macron a
appelé un journaliste du new york times
à la suite de la après que ce professeur
l'assam elle pâtit été égorgées et le
new york times poser des questions sur
la manière dont la france traite et
musulmans notamment en légalisant ce qui
est insultant pour les musulmans à
savoir ses dessins de mahomet qui choque
les musulmans parce que j'arrive pas à
comprendre mais tu sais ce que c'est
qu'il ya deux poids deux mesures c'est
que vous voulez qu'on puisse tenir des
propos contre la religion juive par
exemple mais pas contre les musulmans
pourquoi même pas contre les musulmans
n'ont même contre l'islam parce que
c'est pas du tout contre les musulmans
en l'occurrence si si si si si vous
parlez à des musulmans en dehors d'une
publiquement il soit obligé de dire
écoutez oui ça nous choque un peu mais
enfin c'est la liberté d'expression mais
si vous parler en privé il y en a pas un
qui n'est pas de choquer il faut
respecter les autres cultures et c'est
ce qui manque
la france a toujours considéré que du
fait de sa révolution
c'était un modèle universel qu'est donc
devenu une sorte de modèle occidental
est et l'idée c'est que toutes les
cultures devraient s'aligner
c'est une vieille histoire la france et
les musulmans ça à l'école on apprenait
en 732 charles martel a vaincu les
arabes c'est très anciens cette histoire
il ya eu ensuite les colonisations et
sait rester inscrit dans les gènes de
l'état français cette discrimination
particulière parce que c'est pas le cas
pour les juifs
à part cette période d'occupation où les
autorités ont collaboré avec l'allemagne
nazie
mais pour le reste toutes les religions
les survivalistes qui sont des gens très
dangereux
il ya aucun problème pour dès qu'un truc
qui pèse quelque part on arrête des
arabes musulmans les survivalistes même
quand ils ont des foyers avec des stocks
d'armes
ils n'ont pas beaucoup d'amis oui c'est
deux poids deux mesures quand même
isabelle coûtant peyre on va marquer une
courte pause on se retrouve juste après
[Musique]
de retour dans la grande interview avec
maître isabelle coûtant peyre un avocat
plutôt anti système comme vous allez le
voir alors m vous vous êtes associé avec
jacques vergès un célèbre avocat tout
aussi charismatique que controversé
qu'est ce qui vous a conduit à le
rejoindre
moi j'ai rencontré j'étais pas encore
avocat et puis ensuite quand je suis
devenu avocat je vais croiser au palais
mahdia vous êtes un cas et donc j'ai dit
oui et puis voilà il m'a proposé de
enfin on s'amusait beaucoup en
franchement s'amusait vraiment beaucoup
qu'est ce que vous retenez de ces années
ce que je vous dis on s'amusait beaucoup
c'était donc ses 80 à peu près à
l'époque
la france n'était était encore assez
politisé bien ce qui est plus le cas
aujourd'hui parce qu'on nous parle que
de gestion et d'économie mais mais du
coup il à bout j'ai pas mal
l'arrivée de mitterrand pouvoir avec des
lignes de fond qui était anti mitterrand
même des gens de gauche qui considérait
que c'était ce qu'on appelle un social
traître
donc c'était amusant ensuite vous savez
on parle de gens que j'ai défendue mais
en fait moi j'ai toujours fait du droit
international donc avec vergès était en
faisait beaucoup droit international
arbitrage au niger enfin des choses
comme ça vous vous avez dit qu'à
l'époque dans une interview que l'avocat
avait un peu de pouvoir celui j'ai vu
cité de faire un chai l'état est-ce que
c'était une nécessité pour vous de se
poser à l'époque est ce que c'est encore
valable aujourd'hui
j'irai qu'être avocat enfin sur certains
secteurs
quand on s'aperçoit que l'état triche
parce que pour des raisons x qu'elle
soit démagogique ou pour faire plaisir
je ne sais pas quel groupe social on va
s'acharner contre des gens pour des
raisons
conjoncturel on va dire qu'ils peuvent
ensuite changé avec l'histoire
c'est vrai que c'est intéressant de
d'être au coeur de ce sujet je suis un
peu extraordinaire même j'irai alors
maintenant les états sont devenus un peu
des monstres inaccessible c'est à dire
que l'administration a finalement pris
le pas sur le système politique qui ait
un gouvernement a fortiori ces dernières
années où le régime présidentiel fait
qu'en france les ministres ne sont que
des exécutants et vous avez un président
tout puissant qui décide de tout je vais
faire si je vais faire ça enfin bref il
considère que la seule autorité légitime
pour s'adresser au peuple donc revenir à
ce métier d'avocat
c'est le seul truc vraiment intéressant
tient plus au droit international parce
que quand je parlais du respect des
autres cultures
ce qui m'intéresse est mature passionné
c'est les autres cultures et c'est vrai
que la mondialisation pour moi c'était
un truc un peu désespérant mais quand on
voyage pour des dossiers chalet dans
beaucoup de pays
gelée très souvent en iran j'aime
beaucoup le régime iranien parce que ce
sont des gens extraordinaires
je suis allée book en libye quand
kadhafi était le secrétaire général
le chef et puis dans d'autres pays
d'afrique je vais un cabinet en côte
d'ivoire cabinet secondaire et je
m'occupais de l'agroalimentaire on va
dire agro-industrie donc aller dans
d'autres cultures
ça c'est quelque chose et trouver des
passerelles de communication en
respectant les autres cultures si ça que
j'aime donc aussi avec vergès c'est
comme ça mais alors justement vous vous
avez parlé de pays qui sont pas
forcément jugé comme démocratiques et
vous parlez des pays occidentaux souvent
comme de démocratie artificielle
pourquoi c'est simplement il faut
regarder derrière l'apparence on nous
dit qu'en france et démocratique
bon à la fin les gens sont émus à peu
près par 20% de la population donc c'est
pas réellement représentatif mais vous
avez un régime extrêmement autoritaire
en france vient dé ce qui se passe
depuis des mois et des mois
il ya un prétexte à lithaire c'est une
formidable mais il
la france est capable de créer des états
alors état d'urgence
après 13 novembre 2015 là ils ont repris
les lois contre la les révoltes algerian
contre l'état français ils ont reprises
ces lois lent mais en les aggravant les
gens pouvaient être assigné à résidence
parc l'édition administrative à toute
heure du jour et c'est un bel état
l'état et en plus quand c'est un
président qui décide tout seul ça fait
un bout de temps maintenant
finalement on a de moins en moins de
droit et c'est plus on a inversé la
règle tout ce qui n'est pas permis est
interdite c'est tout ce qui n'est pas
interdit est permis ce dernier a d'abord
les interdictions et ensuite
progressivement la petite marge de
choses que les gens peuvent décider
d'eux-mêmes est en train de disparaître
c'est l'état qui décide de tout y
compris de se promener dans la rue ou
pas c'est quand même extraordinaire
et que pensez vous du choix d'eric
dupond-moretti communiste de la justice
ben justement je l'incité une interview
de journal du dimanche le week-end
dernier le titre
le titre est formidable la justice sans
la police
c'est l'impuissance alors quand vous
avez un avocat qui clamait où les droits
de la défense
contre toute évidence dans certains cas
et carnets à dire que finalement il n'y
a pas de justice
si c'est pas la police qui décide je
crois qu'on n'a jamais atteint ce niveau
demande d'un des morts d'hommes pardon
d'indépendance à l'égard de la police or
ce qui est dangereux c'est la police je
dis pas que les gens qui travaillent
dans la police ont tous des méchants des
gens de mauvaise foi des tricheurs mais
quand on arrive aussi dans un état dit
démocratique à dire que la police c'est
plus important que la justice c'est très
révélateur et c'est grave vous avez fait
votre la fameuse défense de rupture qui
était adoptée par jacques vergès
évidemment par vous également et qui
consiste à mettre en lumière les idées
de l'accusé un a bouleversé une certaine
manière l'ordre établi à ce qu'à notre
époque ça peut encore s'appliquer
on parle c'est une erreur de parler de
défense de rupture défense de rupture
c'est quand y'a pas d'avocat 1 n'était
pas d'avocat pas d'accuser et l'étape
prend ses responsabilités dès lors quand
on est à l'audience et comporte l'as
rome s'est pas tout à fait défaut aux
ruptures se défense tout court parce que
en réalité dans un procès politisé c'est
à dire une question où l'état défend
certain intérêt pas seulement l'intérêt
social mais un intérêt politique
la moindre des choses dans leurs
fonctions le rôle de l'avocat c'est au
moins d'essayer de transmettre même si
les magistrats s'en fiche de transmettre
à l'égard de l'opinion publique si
jamais ça n'intéresse quelles sont les
causes
ils sont cachés qu'on veut cacher aux
gens et donc les causes
je peux seulement dire voilà mon client
est né dans les banlieues il a été
maltraité depuis son enfance pâques
c'est pas ça c'est le d'expliquer
pourquoi l'état a décidé de poursuivre
pénalement de criminaliser on va dire ce
qu'a fait une personne les la loi et la
représentation de la volonté du peuple
c'est ce qu'on dit mais ensuite la
démocratie
représentative ne fait pas correctement
son travail c'est à dire que ça ne
représente pas réellement l'état de
l'opinion publique et surtout quand ça
évolue on ne retire pas les lois donc je
suis très jeu trouve que c'est le
l'essentiel du métier d'avocat eux comme
d'autres professions d'ailleurs
journalistes aussi c'est de parler de la
vérité des vraies choses et non pas de
ce que le système judiciaire par exemple
puisque l'avocat c'est dans le cadre du
système judiciaire a organisé pour
présenter à l'opinion publique donc
c'est bien souvent artificielle et
démagogique
est ce que justement vous dites que vous
n'êtes pas militante mais quelle valeur
vous anime aujourd'hui est ce que c'est
ça justement exposé une vérité la vérité
ou votre vérité c'est à dire je dirais
c'est un peu le syndrome d'antigone
c'est une vision idéale que j'ai mais
face à un appareil qui lui-même n'est
pas idéal puisque il ya rendu par des
êtres humains qui sont soumis à des
pressions qui doivent obéir mais les
magistrats quand ils déplaise bas il ne
monte pas dans la hiérarchie donc il ya
un mécanisme des licences à l'air du
temps qu'a décidé les temps et l'avocat
il doit traverser le temps un jugement à
une époque
bon ça c'est un exemple très courant par
exemple les militants du fln pendant la
guerre d'algérie
c'étaient des terroristes les résistants
en france pendant l'occupation nazie
c'étaient des terroristes et puis
ensuite sont devenus des héros donc
terroriste un jour que mines alain jours
et puis peut-être héros plus tard alors
l'avocat doit avoir essayé en tout cas
de faire une analyse avec un recul que
n'ont pas le droit d'avoir les
magistrats ils doivent juger un moment
tu es sans se dire ah peut-être dans 50
ans ou 200 ans on dira ces de
magistrats c'est vraiment pas bien ce
qu'ils ont fait ils ont condamné des
gens qui ne gêne pas qu'ils sont deux
des roses c'est pas normal donc l'avocat
il doit traverser le temps le magistrat
il est obligé de répondre à la demande
du temps enfin je ne crois pas que les
terroristes d'aujourd'hui
en tout cas ceux qui sont déclarés
coupables et qui ont frappé la france
seront reconnus comme des héros merci
beaucoup m de nous avoir parlé de votre
carrière de vos opinions
à bientôt sur rt france
[Musique]